ich arbeite an einem roman
es ist die geschichte meines lebens und
meiner schwestern machen sie sie kurz
und prägnant und wer die hauptfigur eine
frau ist sollte sie am ende verheiratet
sein
es geht um little women die
literaturverfilmung von greta gerwig in
der es um dieses buch geht und zwar
luisa male kurz buch the women ein
autobiografisch geprägter roman in der
sie ihre eigene kindheit und jugend
aufarbeitet aber wenn man das jetzt
liest dann staunt man vielleicht denn
ziemlich viel übernimmt sie als vorlage
von einem religiösen erbes buch von john
bei mir und das buch erklärt eigentlich
nicht viel anderes als die bibel wollte
man das jetzt unbedingt im kino sich
anschauen dann wahrscheinlich nicht wenn
es nicht auch etwas anderes ging nämlich
darum es geht also um die emanzipation
von frauen es geht darum wie frauen
ihren eigenen weg finden was frauen
alles können und selbst wenn sie so
ungefähr angezogen sind
wieso er hat gesehen wie ihr euer
frühstück verschenkt hat und wollte euch
eine freude macht aber ich dachte er
wäre ein böser alter mann dass es zur
post laurie hat ihm gegen den kopf
gesetzt ich weiß es wir sollten uns mit
ihnen anfreunden
hier muss man angst und das große alte
haus macht wir befinden uns in
neuengland im neunzehnten jahrhundert
es ist die zeit des amerikanischen
bürgerkriegs und vier junge mädchen
wachsen in einem sehr progressiven
haushalt auf und versuchen auf ihre
jeweils eigene art und weise ihren weg
in die zukunft zu finden
wir haben merkt das ist so die hübsche
die gerne heiraten möchte und gerne
einen großen großbürgerlichen haushalt
führen würde
wir haben die eine schriftstellerin
werden würde
und eigentlich nicht gerne heiraten
möchte und er so der tomboy der familie
ist also ein sehr rustikale sehr vitaler
typ frauen
du musst dich gut verheiratet du bist
nicht verheiratet an thematisch kindchen
ich bin ja auch reich dann gibt es amy
amy wäre gerne malerin und ist so ein
bisschen der snob und das nesthäkchen
ein unheimlich herzens gutes mädchen das
aber etwas kränklich ist und ich glaube
das kann verraten weil die geschichte
150 jahre alt ist
das ist eine der großen wendepunkt wir
gehen weg jetzt gleich ich verkaufe
geschichte und du sagtest schauspielerin
sein und ein leben auf der bühne haben
nur weil meine träume anders sind sind
sie deshalb nicht unwichtig es gab jede
menge fernsehen adaption auch es gibt
auch eine trickfilm adaption hörspiele
also die ganze bandbreite aber es ist
eigentlich die vierte richtig große film
adaption breiter gehweg macht zwei dinge
grundsätzlich anders erstens sie geht
nicht chronologisch vor
sie schreitet nicht die lebenswege
dieser jungen mädchen und einen jungen
frauen ab sondern springt mitten rein in
eine phase in der joe schon in new york
lebt sie ist schon eine frau mit
schriftstellerischen ambitionen sie
versucht ihre geschichten zu verkaufen
und dann folgt in vielen rückblenden das
leben davor und fächert sich in vielen
rückblenden im vor und zurückspringen
das leben der drei schwestern und ihr
eigenes leben auf offen gestanden ich
verstehe nicht warum sie nicht den
nachbarn heiratet ja stimmt natürlich
und bin heiratet sie abschluss niemanden
sie heiratet ein von beiden nein das
raffinierte ist dass sie die geschichte
von so viel stärker an die biografie von
luisa market bindet als alle anderen
attraktionen vorher also sie überblendet
eigentlich joe und luisa merkel nein
nein nein das funktioniert nicht aber
sie sagt die ganze zeit dass sie nicht
heiraten wir gehen interessiert mädchen
soll das raumfahrer ratet sind ich
konsequent das ist nicht das richtige
ganz wichtige ende ist das was ich
verkauft
vertrauen sie mir lassen sie die heldin
ihres wundervollen buches als alte
jungfer enden wird ist niemand kaufen es
wäre nicht wird gedruckt zu werden
märz stand vor genau demselben problem
sie sollte eigentlich ihre ihre
hauptfigur so musste sie irgendwie
verheiraten das war einfach der druck
des verlegers sie selbst wollte das
eigentlich nicht und sie selbst ist im
übrigen auch unverheiratet geblieben und
das ist eine der kern dinge die
greta gerwig stark macht in ihrer
verfilmung gibt es einen grund weshalb
du nicht weiter liest aus dem bildschirm
es tut mir leid ich lese weiter pass auf
liebes eines tages wirst du mich
brauchen und wirst wünschen du hättest
dich besser genommen danke tante marge
für diese anstellung und eine
gefälligkeiten aber ich habe vor meinen
eigenen weg zu gehen
niemand geht seinen eigenen weg nicht
wenn wir ehrlich der film ist für sechs
oscars nominiert
greta gerwig hat unverständlicherweise
keine nominierung bekommen dafür aber
sehr schwer ohne die die gespielt und
wie ich finde auch sehr sehr toll spielt
sie rennt ständig durch den film sie ist
einerseits eine sehr sensible eine sehr
sensible figur zeichnet sie da aber
andererseits auch eine sehr robuste die
genau weiß was sie will und und da
versucht auch hinzu kommen und vor allen
dingen eine eine schriftstellerin also
man sieht sie wirklich dabei geht sie
schreibt und und an ihren texten
arbeitet
das wird ganz stark gemacht möchtest du
mit mir tanzen ich kann nicht ich habe
neben kleidern gesenkt ich habe eine
idee wie wir das hinkriegen
und die zweite figur die mir wirklich
gut gefallen hat ist amy amy ich singe
vorherigen verfilmung immer so ein
bisschen so die schlüssel tante unter
diesen geschwistern gewesen
und hier bekommt sie die gelegenheit des
films zeichnet sie und sie bekommt die
gelegenheit zu zeigen was eigentlich
diese figur treibt sie sieht nämlich
dass die einzige möglichkeit
wirtschaftlich unabhängig zu werden wenn
man kein großartiges wirklich richtig
großartiges anderes künstlerisches
talent zum beispiel hat bis die heirat
und das sieht sie mit sehr klaren augen
und kann das auch so formulieren
deshalb wird diese figur eigentlich zum
ersten mal wirklich verständlich
sie wären sein eigentum also sitze ich
da und erzähl mir die er wäre kein
ökonomisches konzept weil sie das ist
was wirklich ein vergnügen ist beim
zuschauen ist wie dynamisch dieser film
ist und wie physisch also dass wir sehen
wir jetzt nicht irgendwelche her könnten
mädchen sondern es wird sich viel um
abend es werden kissenschlachten gemacht
man prügelt sich man rennt man ist tätig
also das ist sehr viel aktion in diesem
film abend so ist es auch so ein
bisschen ermüdend weil wir so hin und
her springt so oft es ist schon so ein
bisschen gemacht für die
aufmerksamkeitsspanne eines goldfisch
aber die haben wir heute alle die hatten
verstand und sie haben eine seele
sie haben nicht nur ein herz und sie
haben ehrgeiz sie haben talent neben
ihrer schönheit ich habe es so satt wenn
die leute sagen dass das liebe das
einzige ist wozu eine frau fähig ist die
kapsel satt aber ich bin ich bin so
allein
ja wer sollte den film sehen also alle
liebhaberin der vorherigen verfilmungen
können sich diesen film getrost
anschauen dass es wird jetzt nichts
kaputt machen für sie alle jüngeren fans
der geschichten von lisa meierkord
können sich das auch anschauen
es ist ein film eigentlich für alle
generationen und es können sich auch
männer diesen film anschauen durchaus
obwohl er mit drin heißt
trainerin durchgebrannt ist und jetzt
ist sein enkel ein waise und verbringt
die ganze zeit in diesem haus
eingesperrt ist ein sehr netter mann er
hat seine tochter verloren als sie noch
ganz klein war aber wie alle adoptionen
von geschichten aus dem 19 jahrhundert
oder von historischen geschichten
überhaupt es ist natürlich so man
erfährt nicht wirklich etwas über diese
zeit
das muss er bedingt man erfährt aber
sehr viel über den blick den wir auf
diese zeit werfen und über das was
unsere generation aus dieser zeit heraus
gehen möchte und dass das ist schon sehr
interessant
es gibt menschen die sind zu stolz um
sich zu beugen
und den heiratet sie am schluss
[Musik]